hundreds and thousands of muslims are
being slaughtered nowhere because he's
obsessed with the jews and so when a jew
defends himself when a jew defends
himself he's gonna make me cry this
panel did you hear that that was amazing
what did you guys think i mean if you
see it from an outside perspective i
would send donations to israel i mean i
mean you guys think about it i was going
to be in tears someone goes anyone got
tissue
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below you can also
use the discount code salam 10 for 10 of
their products
let him talk guys talk let him talk okay
you can talk and you can eat whatever
you want
give him something he might say you know
you're pressing the juicier you know i
don't want to even touch you i feel i
feel disgusted of you but
anyways
jewish
we have to contextualize the conflict
it's not a yes no answer so i will open
with any civilian whatever age whatever
gender any civilian that dies in
conflict is tragic and that is the
tragedy of war so you have to look at
what happened in the later flare of the
violence
so hamas
declared to israel they said told israel
that if you don't pull your troops
out of
sharif of
the temple mount they're going to fire
rockets on israel and they began
fighting rockets of jerusalem they began
firing rockets and israel
they fired hundreds and hundreds of
rockets upon israelis
many of those rockets that hamas fired
in islamic jihad fired i think it was 20
of them fell short on gaza many of the
children that were killed were killed by
islamic
look jihad it anyone is watching this
could google this and look at the fact
they had a failure rate of 20 percent i
can literally name those are from the
al-masri family where i think it was six
of the children were killed and
tragically killed when an islamic jihad
rocket fell short and landed on a family
in gaza in in the latest one when his
followers paid private rockets into
israel literally just before they fired
19 rockets 10 of them fell short in
lebanon it's very common for their
rockets to fall short
so
in this conflict
tragically children have died israel
goes to great lengths to minimize
children so everybody watched the al
jalas tower come down everybody watched
the al-jala tower came down everyone
also watch the idf ring up the owners of
the building and tell them that they're
going to take a strike because thank you
so much
we're going to blow you ali leave the
building i let you smooth your legs you
let me speak i'm so sorry let me speak
so israel went to great lengths to
minimize civilian casualties yep
this year this year alone tens of
thousands of people have been
slaughtered in afghanistan syria yemen
around around the middle east
the middle east is on flames in the
israel-palestine conflict in this latest
clarity talking 200 north of 200 people
were killed yeah just north of 200
people which is a tragedy but when you
look at the
israel has israel could absolutely
annihilate the palestinians it doesn't
it goes to great length to preserve
civilian lives he he was on the street
marching when israelis and the
palestinians made a ceasefire and we
were celebrating the ceasefire the peace
he was protesting israel where was he on
the street for what's happening
in yemen where was he for bequilla
alfassa where was he for nigeria where
was he for any other conflict where
hundreds and thousands of muslims are
being slaughtered nowhere because he's
obsessed with the jews and so when a jew
defends himself when a jew defends
himself
so i i literally did at the beginning i
said
any child any woman any adult any male
any civilian that is killed by israel or
by hamas i mourn their death but what
you have to look at why was there a
conflict israel did not start fighting
rockets on gaza so
islamic jihad started firing rockets on
he said that israel stole the al-aqsa
mosque what actually happened was that
well do you know that you know the
complex the mosque is up here and down
here is where the jews pray because
we're not allowed to pray up here this
is our holy site and we're not allowed
to pray here and they started rioting
and firing rockets and no records like
fireworks and rocks on the jews that
were praying below and they nearly burnt
down
they nearly burned down mastered al-aqsa
with one of their fireworks you all saw
the tree on fire because they were
firing at the jew so israeli israel had
to stop the riots because they were
putting jews and any many many muslims
christians in danger so that's why
israel went in and stopped a riot
a riot
sorry all you going to do
he was going to make me cry this panel
did you hear that that was amazing what
did you guys think i mean if you see
from an outside perspective i would send
donations to israel i mean i mean you
guys think about it i was going to be in
tears some guys everyone got tissue
well now i think i found out tissue we
all start crying the way what is real is
that this mesquite
you know poor
you know the islami the words that he
uses he knows it because you know what
he's an advocacy for israel yeah okay uh
the state of israel um ministry of
strategic affairs were buying ads on our
videos yeah because they knew that
public opinion found good for one bbc
after got heat uh after um the complaint
yeah they had to do a using their man
this is big because there's kills kids
being massacred and we're here
questioning do you condemn hamas do you
condemn hamas what the flipping are you
talking about condemn hamas what are you
talking about kids have been massacred
yeah and this guy would never i dare you
on camera to say i condemn the state of
israel for killing massachusetts 66
children i dare you here you know what
your funding might get caught here okay
so yeah don't worry you'll find out
we'll find out let me speak let me speak
what did he say i don't like the jews
you know you know
you know what it's one of those you
don't need a boxing fight and they go
for the low blow yeah man you're trying
nonsense we know i have here josh i
speak to anyone that knows me and here
when um two jewish people two jewish
friends are called and friends you know
why because they're here we even
arranged to meet with them outside to
have a discussion with hijab about
something happen i was even planning on
going to one of the weddings they do
because i'm really interested in the
whole jewish wedding thing here and so
trust me i would not from your community
because i speak to rabbi uh rabbi beck
in stump video yes rabbi
rabbi
no no no problem yeah yeah ex
communicated rabbi becker got his number
let me tell you something guys guys one
second yeah they're okay have you seen
please yeah if you watch my video on
youtube yeah there's a rabbi who catches
him on the street and refused to
headline me
and he goes rabbi which way are you
going i'm gonna go that way with you
yeah in the video if you see it yeah
he's trying to so you can see rabbi beck
they traveled all the way to islam check
this out here this is what you call
east london and from stanford on the
suburb you're not allowed to get any
cars drive any cars buses they walked
one and a half hour because
you are not close to be his toe yeah
yeah
rabbi rabbi beck and the 15 of them they
walked to a march that we was happy uh
having and we said to him let's drive
you guys back and say we're not allowed
to drive they walked all the way back
one was admired he was like my gosh even
the muslims don't do this yeah okay so
the point is muslims don't do it man
they one and a half hour from stanford
and they walked all the way back yeah so
it was because of the sabbath yeah now
we went to gold is green we had a
campaign we went to the bbc we went to
israeli embassy went to a few places and
our last store was gold is green because
we wanted to speak with the jewish
community yeah because there's zionist
and there's no zionist don't confuse
this guy who's in support of a bloody
massive massacre in state terror uh
group like israel state
so we went there to have a discussion
you know what you you saw the video what
did they say in that video they did it
to themselves do you do you what's that
question i'm gonna now i haven't asked
you a question yet you did you said no i
didn't let me relax relax let me finish
it let me tell you something you know if
you realize i don't even look at you in
the eye yeah not because i can't look in
there because i believe you're a
disgusting vile individual who condones
the king of 66 people that's why i don't
even dare to look at your
i'll abuse you your disgusting face yeah
you can twist and be like i need that
what caused the jewish disc holy
whatever you like we know our stance yet
with the jewish community and this is
why we went there we want this look
there you go we want our state yeah and
now he goes have we seen ali protesting
for year man okay no problem at all have
you seen ali protesting for pakistan
okay no i don't have you seen ali
protestant for this no problem ali
doesn't protest for anyone because i'm
obsessed with palestine arguments saying
how does that justify the killing of 66
kids let's suppose i don't protest for
anyone but palestinian arguments seek
yeah how does that justify the killing
of 66 kids do you accept that those
unfinished were killed by hamas i'm
finished listen let me tell you
something yeah it's clear who's killing
you and where does he go hamas rockets
can you imagine this here how much
rockets apparently what did they do they
targeted he was he's got statistics if
he he follows all the rocket stuff
flying over that land let me see the
road
yeah yeah they may not you turned they
didn't uh
the junction turned yeah now look how
he's justifying this yeah do you condem
i want two things from you yeah do you
condem okay do you condemn
and i want this word by word
the israeli state for massacring and
killing 66 innocent palestinian kids
number one number two do you condemn
that when we went to golden screen we
had two individuals who came and pointed
at our
van of kids kids blown into pieces and
said they have done it to themselves if
i was to do this imagine isis and
someone's competing against isis and
somebody goes as a muslim what do you
think of this other world they've done
it to themselves if i said that i'll be
locked up bounce to guantanamo bay on
first class ticket two questions i asked
you do you condemn them okay so let me
respond in my words not your words not
your straw man so when he turned up to
go the screen and this is for the camera
he parked outside a place where there
are a number of holocaust survivors
people who actually went through the
camps lost their family lost their
parents he parked outside there with a
van and on the side of that van it said
did we not learn from the holocaust so
ali my question to you is what the hell
what the hell can you teach a holocaust
survivor about the holocaust how
obscenely offensive are you to come into
their neighborhood park outside their
house and wave a
huge van like that in their face that's
not coming for a conversation that's
coming to cause gross offense to the
jewish community now i will not will not
condemn the israeli state i will i will
our mission
who goes against their orders and kills
innocent civilians
innocent civilians and that has happened
when an israeli soldier goes roguelike
it happens in any war in any army they
go up against a military tribunal and
there are many of them that are rotting
in jail today because they took law into
their own hands and they killed innocent
people but the overwhelming majority of
the israeli army is incredibly moral and
i'll give you some examples
i'll give some examples and listen and
learn because you don't hear this
perspective you don't hear this
narrative
josh josh
according to him i don't i hate you
because you're a jew no okay i don't
like josh look
last time you know when he came in you
came and said hi to me here i said to
you you do remember i said to you i said
i hate you you jew yeah do you remember
that josh yeah i'm so sorry about that
mate yeah carry on bro there we go there
we go
so
when and when an israeli soldier
needs to take unless it's actually in a
combat situation they need a ring and
get permission
from their commander to actually even
take a shot so i'm going to give you
some real examples of what happened in
this gaza war
so in this gaza war hamas are firing
rockets and islamic jihad of firing
rockets from incredibly built up
civilian areas they've been condemned by
the united nations relief work agency
which is overwhelmingly stuffed by
palestinians overwhelmingly for
restoring their rockets under united
nations relief work agency skills for
firing rockets hamas central command is
under a hospital yeah so what israel
does is engaging with a combatant which
is in an incredibly built up civilian
area now if israel were to hit
disproportionately you would see
thousands and thousands of innocent
palestinian palestinians killed that's
not what happens we can literally name
all of the people that were killed in
the latest conflict the overwhelming of
the number of those 200 people that were
killed were islamic jihad fighters and
the massive fighters i can show you the
actual shaheed posters of them
holding their weapons and if you join
the hamas telegram channel if you join
the islamic jihad telegram channel they
have telegram channels you scroll back
to the conflict you can see the shaheed
posters of the the so-called martyrs who
were killed in combat and so
what israel will do it will do
everything it can to minimize civilian
casualties so the first thing it does
when it's going to strike it drops
leaflets into an area saying there is
going to be it's going to be a ground
incursion we're going to massacre you
there's going to be an incursion please
move your civilians to safe places we
kind of hamas are engaging us from your
neighborhood we need to respond the next
thing they do
is they will if it's striking a
particular building like the al-jala
tower which you also come down they will
bring up the tower in advance and say
hamas are operating from this we
they've got five minutes to leave the
building and you can literally see the
landlord pleading with the idf please we
need to go in and get equipment for the
the for the al jazeera or the ap and
they say no it's going out what they
then do they do what's called a knock on
the roof and they drop a non-lethal
explosion above the roof to say this
building is now coming down finally they
do a flyover and if they see civilians
they are born and you can watch videos
of this happening if you take idf
youtube to youtube you can see why
because so
for me how can i stop someone that's
doing my job for me he's talking i'm not
gonna condemn israel state israeli state
terrorism
please yeah so what ali and what many of
the people in the crowd are asking i
just want to point out there's one of me
and about
let me make it better 50 jihadis
one has won his mast and he might have a
gun underneath and over here this guy
looks a bit dangerous anyways oh here we
go here we go
one second
right look at his face by someone
who was a muslim well one second has it
been established who is it ali who do
you think do you have intelligence i
don't know who he is you don't know i
don't know who he is
because the thing is who would harbor a
grudge against hatu a person maybe an
ex-husband maybe a family member maybe a
muslim maybe a christian that slept
there a couple of years ago so there you
go so stop trying nonsense yeah have you
guys noticed yet can i finish my okay
quickly please okay i'll tell you what
you've got thank you very kind very kind
indeed yeah just don't kill palestinians
well okay i don't need your kindness
yeah you see these pictures yeah okay
who are these
you're ashamed i want to look as well
brother on my face so this one is true
okay yes yes that one's jewish yeah okay
look how look what you're saying i said
to ask him two questions yeah do you
condemn one of them he done a
no no i said one second
my friend if someone comes to me if
someone comes and says to me do you
condemn isis first things what not to do
with me but if i said i don't condem
isis i kill some of the things the
soldiers isis members did look prophetic
how pathetic you are yeah so it's very
clear very very clear you know you're in
big big trouble you're in a holy dignity
of deeper these are 66 children that's
been killed look how you're making all
the hamas
israel sends a letter and then sends the
thing and throws some flowers and then
says what the hell are you talking about
my 66 kids have been massacred what the
hell are you talking about um israel
does this israel can imagine israel goes
to length to minimize casualty can you
imagine if this is the length they go to
to minimize casualty and 66 children
have died can you imagine if they were a
bit reckless if they're not reckless and
66 kids are dying can you imagine if
israel is reckless yeah okay we know how
the idea of soldiers have crossed all
boundaries all the time yeah my point is
this you haven't condemned the state of
israel and not only that i'll ask you
again there was an individual do you
believe that the palestinians have done
that to themselves do you condemn the
words that because i know you're going
to get in trouble because i know you see
face to face with these individuals and
they're going to say to you why did you
condemn us two people said that
is this afghanistan they're mocking the
devs oh this is walking past like this
is this afghanistan mate i said what the
[ __ ] you talking about afghanistan here
you know what it is do you condemn
direct answer the individual who said
they did this to themselves okay so
again i'll answer so i don't know what
was said before you're a waste man you
are a waste man bro what are you talking
about no no no anymore anymore
you're a waste man terrorist supporter
you are you are as good as the killing
of 66 kids you play a role just the way
just the way you said that my friend
over there he's sharing the
uh the same shampoo as your wife
apparently l'oreal you have the same
blood on your hands as your terrorist
state israel yeah and tell them to stop
buying bloody ads on our youtube because
we block them they're desperate they
made their campaign of rockets flying
and
this we look like let me tell you
something yeah hamas or no hamas anyone
that kills innocent people i don't give
a damn if it's hamas i don't care who it
is yeah killing innocent people is haram
but under un law they are allowed to um
armed resistance the point is the
following what's established here and
this is my closest statement you can
talk as much as you like yeah i will
guys
guys guys yeah run off wherever you are
i'm actually going to run over here okay
guys very clearly you can see that he
will not condemn the state of israel
terrorist state of israel
66 kids had died killed if i did what he
did i'll be on daily mail the jewish
chronicles new york times flipping
everywhere okay i'll make it very clear
yes i know daily
it's a badge of honor for me to be on
daily mail i'm like salute i'm happy
yeah i don't care about that the point
is this you haven't condemned the 66
killing
from your israel terrorist state israel
you haven't you didn't even condemn the
guy who said they have done it to
themselves you know what that means
you are as
you are as good as an isis fighter
coming to the park and justifying the
actions of isis yeah you are a scum
terrorist supporting scumbag i'll tell
you to your face because i don't like
being shy yeah i don't look at your face
because you're vile if you've noticed
look at your face yeah you're disgusting
i'd rather look at this gentleman's face
yeah you are disgusting value terrorist
supporting 66 killing children yeah
that's it you can have your little
statement of israel sent flowers before
they bombed it
this is why jews need their own state
they